Hello.
Hello,
and welcome to simulation.
Ooh.
Hello.
Hello everyone.
I'm your host Allen sock yarn.
I'll be your beacon of
curiosity this evening.
Simulation Paris together,
global leaders with humanities,
most thought provoking questions
and we hope to fill Levi stadium.
We hope to scale these thought provoking
conversations up to the size of Levi
stadium because if the national football,
we can do it.
So can the scientists,
am I right?
Yeah.
Through it.
All right.
You guys know who your guest is.
Well,
let's give him a little bit
of San Francisco Bay area La.
Yeah,
baby.
Yeah.
Yeah,
baby.
[inaudible].
It's a lot of noise
for a bunch of lefties.
Well,
thank you.
That's a,
yeah,
that's completely overwhelming.
Yes.
Thank you very much.
Ooh,
San Francisco Barrier welcomes you.
Huge welcome.
Do you see the lobster?
I do.
I sit in the last year.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Lobsters everywhere.
I guess they just made the lobster Emoji.
Uh,
that seems syncronous right.
Seems like a synchronous event.
It's quite funny.
I,
I want the one where
you're riding the lobster,
you can buy those posters if you're
really into that sort of thing.
New fetishes.
Yeah.
Oh Jordan,
where do we even start?
Well,
you're the interviewer.
Amazing,
amazing work over the last year.
You for me,
someone that you remind
me of is Tony Robbins.
I think he's taller.
Uh,
someone that knows how to
inspire people to self actualization.
And I find that to be
deeply needed in our world.
And that's what you've been
doing and it's brilliant.
It's beautiful.
And I think this is why you
bring people together like this.
So,
so something that you brought to the
attention of so many people is the
dominance or competence hierarchy.
Y W let's maybe talk about what's,
what's the difference?
Dominance or competence hierarchy.
I kind of like competence hierarchy.
Yeah,
it's better.
Yeah.
Well I got this colleague,
his name is Daniel Higgins and I've
been working with him for like 25 years.
He helped me design the
self authoring suite,
which is a series of programs,
writing programs that are online that
helped people write about their lives,
their past.
And their present,
their virtues and their faults
and to make a plan for the future.
And,
um,
we've talked a lot.
He,
he was,
uh,
he has a master's degree
in MIT in engineering.
And then he went to Harvard.
He was a student of mine there and he
got a phd in experimental psychology.
And we've been working
on these psychological
interventions online ever since.
And we talk fairly frequently.
And I'd been using the term
dominance hierarchy a lot,
which it's something that's used
by biologists very regularly,
right?
Because most social animals,
even animals that aren't social,
any animals that have to compete for
occupation of a specific territorial space
tend to organize themselves into
fairly predictable hierarchies.
And it's,
it's,
it's a biological universal that's
a good way of thinking about it,
which is something
really important to know,
right?
Because if you don't know that,
then you might think that hierarchical
organizations are some secondary
consequence of a sociopolitical structure
and economic structure or something
like that.
And it's just,
that's just not true.
It isn't even a little bit true.
It's unbelievably not true.
And well,
um,
this is partly why in rural
and 12 rules for life,
I wrote about the nervous system of
crustaceans and in rule number one,
because the neural biological systems
that we have evolved or that have evolved
to deal with dominance,
hierarchy,
placement,
and I'll get to the
competence issue in a minute,
are at least a third
of a billion years old,
and that's far longer than theirs.
That's,
that's there weren't trees a
third of a billion years ago.
So dominance,
hierarchies,
hierarchical organizations among
animals are older than trees.
It's like there's no
blaming them on capitalism,
right?
This
is,
it's just,
well,
seriously,
hierarchies have problems that
they're problematic social structures,
but you can't blame them on,
on,
on cultural,
you can't blame them on culture.
Anyways,
we were talking about dominance
hierarchies and Dr. Higgins said,
you can't call them dominance hierarchies.
I said,
why not?
he said,
well,
unless you're in an organization where
you can put a dog leash around someone's
neck and lead them around,
it's not a dominance hierarchy.
And I thought he's kind of blunt as he
might've notice by that comment kind of
shocked me a because,
because it was so blunt.
There's lots of that that
happens in San Francisco.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well the thing is,
well,
you know that that's actually an operable
comment because dominance is just as
old as sexuality,
perhaps.
Perhaps not quite as old.
It's not quite as old as sexuality,
but it's old enough so that the
two things get tangled together.
Very,
very inevitably.
He said,
he said two things that I thought were
really interesting and the first was
that,
okay,
human organizations are
sufficiently complex,
so the dominance is an insufficient
means of establishing hierarchy gold
priority.
That's good.
And I thought,
that's right.
I knew that as soon as he said that,
I thought,
yeah,
I shouldn't be using the term dominance
hierarchy because friends de wall,
who's Dutch primatologist wrote a series
of excellent books on the emergence of
morality and chimpanzees.
I would highly recommend them.
They're very interesting books.
One of the things do all noted was
that in chimpanzee hierarchies,
the brutal males can rise to the top,
but they tend to have very short
lived empires and to meet very,
very violent deaths.
And so his conclusion was that in order,
even for a chimpanzee hierarchy
to be stable across time,
then they top chimp had
to be quite pro social.
So first of all had to engage
in sufficient reciprocal
behavior so that he had
allies among other males.
Right.
Because otherwise,
if you're like top chimp and
your cavemen strongman type,
and you've established dominance
merely as a matter of intimidation and
strength,
then if you have an off day,
two of your slightly weaker
opponents can tear you to pieces,
which is exactly what the chimps do
because they're quite brutal in there.
There's no evidence that chimpanzees
have any internal regulation of the
violence that they'll
use to shift dominance,
hierarchy position.
And so you end up castrated,
for example,
by your opponents,
which is something that the
wall noted in the RNM zoo.
So he found that the stable chimp
troops had males at the helm.
Yeah.
Who were,
who had friendships,
because chimps actually have social
friendships really that can stretch across
many years,
decades even,
and that they track them very well,
very reciprocal and their behavior tended
to treat the females relatively well
by chimp standards and
also tended to pay a fair,
a fair amount of attention to the infants,
which is an unbelievably
important finding,
right?
Because it,
it indicates at a,
at a level that's below the human,
let's say that there's an ethic associated
with leadership that isn't a mere
consequence of raw power.
And then,
so that was the first thing
that Higgins pointed out in.
The second thing was that he thought,
and,
and I haven't,
I don't know how true this is yet.
He thought that some of
what the pathologists who
had used the term dominance
hierarchy to apply to animals might have
been doing was using an intrinsically
Marxist framework to interpret animal
behavior and to overestimate the degree to
which dominance was actually the,
the,
the core foundation of
hierarchical organizations,
even among animals and the first ones,
the first objection he had,
that's definitely the case.
This is true.
The second one,
it's an interest.
Competence.
Yeah.
Well the idea that that it's pure
power is an unstable basis for,
for,
for uh,
stable hierarchy.
That's well documented and I think that
has probably moved into the realm of
empirically verifiable fact.
The second one that the initial idea
that it was dominance per se that was at
the basis of hierarchical arrangements
was in part a quasi I Marxist
interpretation or projection.
I think that's disputable because I
think what happens is that as you go down
the,
um,
the Fila genetic chain to
simpler and simpler animals,
it looks more and more like power.
Physical Prowess essentially
is the determining factor.
It certainly seems to be
the case among lobsters,
for example,
crustaceans,
they're of interest because
they have seen their lobster.
Um,
they have relatively simple
nervous systems relatively,
they're still very complex with large
neurons that are easily observable and uh,
and a neurochemistry that differs
from humans but is the same.
It's similar in very interesting ways.
And maybe an example of using skills
that aren't power based or things like
creativity to be able to find ways
to get food or get what you want.
You might want to figure out
how you would define competence.
And so there's a
psychometric answer to that.
So I can metric psychometricians are
psychologists who are particularly
interested in measurement and then
also in measurement and prediction.
And so one of the things you want to
predict are the various human outcomes,
like,
like economic success,
let's say,
or or,
or subjective wellbeing,
which is something that Sam
Harris is quite excited about.
10 or general quality of life.
These things are hard to measure,
but you can measure economic success.
Um,
what,
and what you find is that,
well there are a variety of features
that predict economic success in the
Western world.
The most outstanding of those are Iq.
So that's straight intelligence.
And intelligence is something
like processing speed and
working memory capacity.
So it's the ability to
manipulate variables,
a number of variables simultaneously
at relatively high speeds.
That's their abstract variables.
And that so that,
you know,
there's still people who debate
about the existence of Iq,
but they're called fools
fundamentally because,
well,
look,
I mean there's no,
there's absolutely no doubt that Iq is
the most documented phenomena in the
social sciences except for one thing.
There's one only one thing
I've ever seen that that is,
has been measured more
powerfully and accurately.
And that was the correlation between
inequality across counties in the United
States and male homicide rate because
that correlation is about 0.9.
And you know,
like that's just,
you'd never see that the
correlation between Iq and
success depending on how you
measure academic success,
learning speed,
um,
economic success,
success as a,
as a manager and administrator
success as an entrepreneur,
you're an entrepreneur or creative agent.
The correlation between that and
Iq is about 0.5 which is about
three times roughly speaking.
Yeah,
three times,
two to three times as powerful as the
most typical next powerful order of
effects that science
social scientists measure.
So Iq is at walloping effect.
So I accused the first
one hardly surprising.
I mean,
especially as the environment gets more
complex because Iq predicts performance
in complex jobs better than it
predicts performance in simple jobs.
And a simple job is one where you learn
it and then you repeat what you've
learned.
Whereas a complex job is a
job that changes every day.
So I suspect most of you in the audience
have complex job and performance in
well I suspect so you know,
um,
and maybe performance with
complex thinking as well
as long as the environment
that you're,
that you're operating in changes on a
relatively frequent basis than you have to
have an eye high Iq to
manage it effectively.
That's basically what Iq measures.
And then the next most,
um,
relevant predictor is
trait conscientiousness,
which is not a trait.
We understand that all,
we have no measures of
conscientiousness that work.
We've got a couple of week ones,
but no measures that really work better
than self report and other report could
being meticulous be a good way
to explain conscientiousness.
Meticulousness is associated with
orderliness and orderliness is one of the
aspects of conscientiousness,
but conscientious people.
The best way to sum up a conscientious
person is that they're very good at
keeping contract with
themselves and others.
So what a conscientious person will do
is first of all say that they'll do some
things.
So that's the first thing,
but then they'll actually do it.
So they seem to be able to,
and they seem to be able to crucial.
Well,
yeah,
it's just,
it's,
it's crucial if it's especially crucial
if you're a manager and administrator,
it's not so crucial if
you're an entrepreneur,
if you want to hold
yourself to achieving goals.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well they,
they,
they tend to be,
if you want to work your way
up the competence hierarchy,
probably a good way to do that is to
say I'm going to do something and do it.
Yes.
Well,
well that's the thing
that these are these,
this isn't,
this isn't rocket science,
let's say.
Um,
market surgery as,
as,
uh,
one of the favorite characters of a
show I like in Canada tends to say that
that's the trailer park
boys rocket surgery,
which I think is really funny anyways.
I mean,
Lord for,
so for a social science finding,
it's pretty damn self evident,
right?
Smart people who work hard do better.
And but what that,
what that,
what's also really cool
about that and this,
it isn't viewed this way very often.
It's like,
let's say that you were
going to psychometrically
validate the integrity of an
economic system.
So you'd say,
well you take the smart people in the
hardworking people and see if they do
better.
And if the answer is no,
then the system is rotten,
right?
I mean,
doesn't that make sense?
Because you'd expect,
you'd hope if a system is
functioning that faster,
harder working people would
be better at whatever it does.
And it turns out that in our culture,
in the western culture,
the correlation between
conscientiousness plus Iq,
you have to wait the two and longterm
life success is as high as 0.7,
which is walloping walloping correlation
given how much chance also contributes
to success,
right?
Because you can be working hard and very
smart and then you get cancer and die.
And that's the end of that.
Like there are lots of random events in
life that interfere with your movement
forward.
And so there's an eradicable degree of
chance that that prediction is not going
to overcome.
Plus we're not that good
at measuring success.
So there's,
there's error on the success
end of the measurement as well.
But IQ and conscientiousness
goes a long ways.
Yeah.
So,
and that's competence,
you know?
And then we,
the other thing we might think about
with regards to defining a competence
hierarchy is imagine that
one of the things you want
from the operators within a
hierarchy is that they
maintain the hierarchy and
they expand it so that it can
include other people.
Right?
And so competence,
a good measure of competence would be
the ability to work within the hierarchy
while you're also expanding,
maintaining it and expanding it.
And so that means that you would want to
set up an economic system where smart,
hardworking people were doing things
that made other people who weren't them
rich too.
I think we're actually
pretty good at that.
You know,
if you look at the statistics,
here's a good one and this is why people
shouldn't be as pessimistic as they are
likely.
It's a good feeling to make other people
well off and have their wellbeing be
bought and lots of people,
I mean one of the things I've really
been struck by with the people that I've
known who are hyper competent is that
one of the things they really like to do
is to find young people who need
opportunities and open doors for them.
I mean it's a,
it's a,
it's a pleasure that's not well measured,
you know,
but I know that like I've seen that
among the professors that I've known,
that I really admired,
like they really like to mentor graduate
schools and graduate students and
develop their careers and entrepreneurs
in silicon valley that I know the same
thing.
And good managers and administrators,
they're not playing a zero sum game.
They're not opening the doors to everyone,
I wouldn't say.
But they're definitely always looking
around for competent people who are young
to provide opportunities to.
And it's a real unsung virtue
of capitalism that that
sort of thing occurs and
it's not rare.
So,
so,
so well.
So back to the,
to the ICU and conscientiousness
connection is like,
um,
like with regards to the say the,
the broad capitalist that broad
capitalists social and economic structure,
you know,
I don't know if you guys know this,
but the UN said is one of its millennial
goals in the year 2000 to have the
rates of poverty in the
world by 50% within 15 years.
Right?
And we hit that in 2012,
three years ahead of schedule.
It was the fastest decrease in human
poverty that has ever occurred in the
history of the planet by a massive margin.
And it hasn't quit.
Now.
Obesity is a bigger problem
now than starvation.
It's like we should have
party in the street for that,
right?
There's more faculty than
there are starving people.
You know,
it's a perverse sort of victory,
but,
but it's a big one and about 300,000
people a day right now are being plugged
into the electrical grid and the fastest
growing economies are in sub Sahara
Africa,
sub Saharan Africa.
It's like there's some real reason to
be thinking things are going great and
they're having Amazon and Alibaba compete
to provide them with those goods that
they need every single day.
Yeah,
well they have cell phone technology
that's really made a big difference and
help stabilize the currencies and help
them identify where the proper market is
for their goods and their being plugged
into youtube and watching Jordan B.
Peterson videos now.
Yes.
Well what can I say?
So Jordan,
Jordan.
So competence hierarchies.
It's,
look,
it's better.
It's better to think.
It's better to think of a well functioning
human hierarchy as one based on
competence.
The other thing,
like my colleague said to me was that
you don't want to overestimate how much
power people have,
let's say in a corporate environment
because it's not obvious at all that the
managers or the executives
for that matter,
except in the rare cases
where they're psychopathic,
have fewer strictures,
have,
well sometimes you get
psychopaths that rise to the top,
right?
I mean,
otherwise there wouldn't be psychopaths.
But,
um,
it isn't obvious that people higher up
in a competence hierarchy have fewer
strictures on their moral behavior
than people lower in the hierarchy.
Right?
Because my sense is that responsibility
increases as you move up the hierarchy.
And so,
and your degrees of freedom with regards
to moral attitude also tend to decline
because you're,
you know,
if you're a manager of,
well maybe you have 30 people working
for you and they each only have one
manager.
There's a lot of people
that you're responsible to.
And so,
and you can't miss.
You can't mistreat your people
with any degree of consistency because
the good ones leave the bad ones torture
you to death.
And the whole thing collapses across time.
And so the whole idea that what you
have in a competence hierarchy is power
is not a reasonable assumption
as far as I can tell.
That's a big deal,
right?
We read,
you've got to get that right.
So it's a big deal.
And the word competence
is an empowering word.
I've achieved the status that I have,
whoever's speaking these words,
by competence,
and then there's better mates,
better food,
less disease,
et Cetera,
to climb higher.
Now since you,
since you bring this up,
I think this is an important point and
that I really wanted to ask you about,
which is that what percentage of the
competence hierarchies influenced by
potentially an exertion
of oppression for giving?
Let me give you an example.
For example,
let's go ahead and take
our friendly lobster.
Uh,
let's take the lobster for example.
Let's say the lobsters,
a sea floor dwelling preacher,
and the lobster has 20 shelters,
but the lobster only
inhabits two of the shelters.
But it doesn't enable the other lobsters
to dwell or reside in the other 18
shelters that it doesn't even use.
Just as an example.
Well,
I mean it's,
we could,
we could think about this.
One of the things that I've found very
interesting about looking at archetipal
representations of experiential reality
is that there are always balanced.
And so the fundamental
architectural representation
of the hierarchy is the wise
king and the tyrant and every hierarchy
can be reasonably represented with
narratives involving the
wise king and the tyrant.
So the wise king is the part of the
hierarchy that sustains itself and expands
and includes more people,
right?
So that's a functioning polity.
And the tyrant is the fact that people
operating within that hierarchy can play
zero sum games,
can be willfully blind,
can be malevolent,
can play politics,
can cease to be productive,
can manipulate the system for
their own devices and all of that.
And it's obviously the case
that every human institution,
especially as they scale falls prey to
the [inaudible] part of the archetype.
That's why big things fall apart.
And so when you say,
well to what degree is a hierarchy,
to what degree does a hierarchy
emerge because of tyrannical factors?
The answer is,
well it depends on the hierarchy,
but generally a nontrivial
amount that scales with size.
Okay.
But that,
having said that,
that doesn't to say that something is
partially corrupt is a lot different than
saying that it's totally corrupt.
Right?
There's this great story for those of
you that don't know it in the brothers
Karamazov and the
atheist Ivan,
who's the most compelling character,
I would say most charismatic character
in the book is torturing his younger
brother,
Lee Osha,
who's a monastic novitiates
about religion and Dogma and God.
And he's trying to convince Ellie
Osha that if there is a god,
he's so cruel that he's reprehensible
in his fundamental element.
And anyways,
he tells this story about the Catholic
Church and it's called the grand
inquisitor.
It's a very,
very famous story.
And in this story,
Christ come back,
comes back to Earth to Seville in
Spain at the height of the Spanish
inquisition.
And he's,
he reappears and he's doing
miraculous things and you know,
dividing up the loaves and feeding the
poor and healing the sick and being
miraculous and wonderful.
And the grand inquisitor who runs the
Spanish inquisition promptly has him
arrested and throws him in prison.
And then he,
and,
and he's,
he,
he decides he's going to be executed and
he comes to visit them at night and he
says,
look,
you know,
you were here 1500 years ago and you're,
you were perfect and you put a moral
burden on human beings that was way too
great for anyone to carry.
And it's taken us 1500 bloody years to
cobble together something out of your
insanely positive example that
normal human beings could live with.
And we finally got it a little bit
under control and damp and it down.
And here you are back again,
like setting up an impossible
example for people.
We just can't have that.
We're going to do you in tomorrow.
And,
um,
Christ listens and is not particularly
upset by all appearances about what's
happening.
And then the inquisitor who's
an old man gets up to leave.
And when he leaves,
Christ stands up and kisses him
on the lips and the inquisitor,
it turns white with shock and then leaves.
And when he leaves,
he leaves the door open.
And that's the brilliant
part of this story because,
and that's what made Dostoyevsky
such an amazing genius,
I would say,
is even though he could write a
critique of the Catholic church,
let's say the Christian Church is
powerful and is intelligent as the grand
inquisitor.
He also noticed that the
dogmatic structure of the
church still left the still
left the door open for
the divine individual.
It's like you don't get a hierarchy
without getting a tyranny along with it,
you know?
But,
but there's a hell of a difference between
the 30 or so countries in the world
where anyone with any
sense would want to live.
And the other hundred and 50 where that
are basically run by barbaric thugs.
And it's important to keep the distinction
between those two things in dine.
It's like,
yeah,
we've got some things that we
should put together and clean up.
And you know,
people are discriminated against for
unfair reasons and that's to everyone's
detriment,
obviously,
but it's a multivariate problem.
And the,
the,
the positioning of someone in a hierarchy
of competence is in part due to there.
What would you say to the historical
context within which that hierarchy has
emerged?
But to say it's all a consequence
of that is part of what I regard as
the radical leftist war on
the idea of competence itself.
Because I actually think that's the
fundamental narrative driving the real
radical leftists is that they hate
the idea of competence itself.
It's deeper than Orwell's comment.
George Orwell's comment in,
in,
uh,
road to Wigan pier where he said,
well,
the problem with middleclass
pretty socialist is that
they don't like the poor.
They just hate the rich,
which is like dead on man
vicious vicious diagnosis.
It's worse than that.
Is that,
is that the radical leftists
don't like the oppressed.
They just hate the competent.
I really believe that.
I think it's,
I think it's unbelievably
pathological and dangerous.
It is.
So the more nuanced conversations like
these rather than binary yes or no sort
of reductionist conversations around
complex topics like a competence hierarchy
that's surface to fruition
in the media sphere.
I think over time we will get to a point
where more and more people have the
really complex and nuanced
conversation about this.
Um,
Jordan,
how about the genetic fitness landscape?
Is this,
is it fair to say that there are a bunch
of different competence hierarchies
across this plain of fitness competent?
Well,
there are and there are one or the,
you know,
one of the bubbles could be who's ranked
highest in the government or one of
them is who's ranked highest in space
or whose rank Tyson genetic engineering
and or whatever field in whatever.
But that's why ideas like multiple
intelligence are so attractive,
even though the idea of
multiple intelligence is wrong,
it's clear.
No,
it's clearly,
it's clearly wrong intelligence.
The factor analysis have been done
and we've known this since like 1920.
It's,
it's not disputable if you,
if,
so,
here's how you make an Iq test.
It's really easy and everyone
should know this because you need,
you need to know how these things work.
So imagine that you took a
universal library of questions.
Any sort of question that required
abstraction to solve could be a general
knowledge question.
It could be a vocabulary question,
could be a mathematical question.
It doesn't matter.
It could be a question about anything
as long as it requires abstraction to
solve.
So you have a universal
library of those questions.
Then imagine you took a hundred questions
at random from that universal library
and you gave them to 500 people and
then you just totaled their scores,
right?
Right,
wrong,
total total discourse.
Then you rank ordered the scores from
highest performer to lowest performer.
That's Iq.
That's all there is to it.
That's it.
And then what you'd find is if you took
another hundred questions from the same
library,
randomly selected and gave
them to the same 500 people,
and you'd have to rank orders
right from the top to the bottom,
the correlation between the two rank
orders would be about 0.9 unbelievably
high.
It's unbelievably stable.
And now if you correct that for age,
you get Iq.
That's all there is to it.
That's it.
And so well now,
so cause intelligences,
and that's a single factor.
If you do a factor analysis,
which is a statistical technique that
tells you how many different attributes
that that rank ordering possesses,
you get one factor.
So it's one that's that not multiple.
Now there are multiple talents and there
are multiple temperaments and that's
where the big five model comes in.
So people,
different extroversion and extroverts
are more likely to be good at sales jobs.
People differ in negative emotionality
despite what the California Labor board
ruled yesterday.
Um,
people differ in sensitivity
to negative emotion.
Women are more sensitive on average
to negative emotion than men.
And the effect size of that is something
like if you took a random woman and a
random man out of the population and
you had to lay a bet on who had higher
levels of anxiety and emotional pain and
you bet that it was the woman you'd be
right 60% of the time.
So it's an interesting stat because
men and women are more the same in
emotional,
in sensitivity to negative
emotion then different.
But there's,
there's a,
there's an offset at the mean.
And what that also means is that
if you took the top 100 people,
top one in a hundred people who are
the most sensitive to negative emotion,
they'd almost all be women.
Now you see the re,
you see the inverse of that in some
sense with regards to criminality.
So males are more aggressive than females.
And it's about the same difference.
If you take a random woman on a
random man out of the population,
you had to bet on who
was the most aggressive.
If you bet it was the man,
you'd be right 60% of the time,
which isn't that much of the time,
right?
It's,
it's deviation from 50 50 but it's not
90 10 it's just 60 40 but if you take the
one in a hundred persons
who's most aggressive,
and that's the person you throw in prison,
by the way,
they're all men.
Nine out of 10 of them are men.
And so one of the things,
and this,
this goes to the complexity argument
that you were talking about earlier,
that it's hard for people
to have a multivariate,
uh,
discussion because we like to
collapse things into single causes,
but it's also hard for people to
understand the statistical reality of
distribution because you can have two
distributions that almost entirely overlap
and have walloping differences at the
tails and the tails are where all the
action is.
Like who cares how aggressive you are
as long as you don't shoot or stab
someone,
you get to be aggressive.
But if you're so aggressive that,
or you shoot or stab someone,
then you end up in prison and you're
the person that we're concerned with.
And maybe that's 1% of the population.
It's like,
yeah,
well they're all men.
And you see this happens in less dramatic
form too when you look at phenomena
like a career selection.
So it was just a data set
released the other day.
And this is the first time I'd seen this
showing quite clearly that as this is a
w this is a remarkable finding and it
builds on some earlier research which the
California Labor board also
decided with pseudoscience,
which is absolutely
100% not pseudoscience.
That is so wrong.
No serious scientists debate the data
that I'm describing that nobody has
debated it since like 1990.
So it,
it's very well settled science.
Um,
if you look out career
choices between men and women,
what you find is that they're driven in
large part by temperamental differences.
So that would be in the big five,
extroversion,
neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness and openness and
also by interest because the biggest
difference between men and women that's
been measured psychometrically forget
about the physical differences.
But the psychological differences is
difference in interest and it's actually
pretty big.
And so men on average are more interested
in things and women on average are
more interested in people.
And it's a one standard
deviation difference,
which is a big difference by by the
standards of these sorts of differences.
And it's enough to drive the f drive.
A couple of phenomena phenomena.
One,
most nurses are women phenomena
to most engineers are men.
Why has nothing to do
or very little to do,
if any,
with differences in
mathematical reasoning ability.
And I mean that's being tracked too.
So if you take junior high kids,
men and women,
girls and boys,
and you take only those who are off the
charts in terms of their mathematical
interest,
the gender difference isn't that great.
There's a tiny edge for for boys,
but not much.
And it's even disputable
whether that edge exists.
So let's assume it doesn't
for the sake of argument,
if you track those kids across time,
what you find is a disproportionate
number of the men go into the stem fields
and hardly any of the women.
And the reason is they're good at it,
but they're not interested in it.
So [inaudible] then you might think,
well that's socio-cultural white.
We could change that.
It's like,
no,
sorry.
Research has already been done.
Um,
what a,
so imagine you could rank order
countries by how gender neutral there are
socioeconomic policies were.
And then you put the Scandinavian
countries at the top for obvious reasons
because they'd been pushing
that for like three decades,
four decades,
and have made a lot of progress with it.
Um,
the biggest differences in temperament
and interest in the world between men and
women are in the Scandinavian countries.
And the data now have revealed that
there's a correlation between how gender
neutral the country is and how big the
differences are between the men and
women.
And the difference is positive,
not negative.
And then you think,
well,
is that reliable science or,
or are the right wing conservatives
driving this scientific agenda?
And answer to that is there are no
right wing conservatives in psychology.
There are none.
I'm dead serious,
man.
I'm dead serious about that.
So,
so here's why this,
here's why this research is reliable.
It's because the research is reliable
because the people who generated the
findings hated them.
They hated the findings.
They were completely biased in the
other direction because everyone,
everyone was hoping.
Everyone who's a social scientist was
hoping that as you flattened out the
gender differences in the
sociological landscape,
you would decrease the
personality differences,
individual differences.
And that's not what happened.
You maximize them.
Instead it's like,
oh,
that wasn't what we expected.
And,
and believe me,
people just didn't run to the
publisher and publish these data sets.
They were shocked by them
and so they replicated them.
And these have been replicated across
samples of tens of thousands of people
and,
and dozens of countries.
It's extraordinarily reliable.
It is,
as far as I'm concerned,
apart from the hard
biological end of this,
of psychology where there's some
unbelievably solid work done.
It's the most solid social science
that exists as far as I can tell the
psychometric data.
And the reason I think that is when,
when I was starting my career,
I was looking for the most solid data
because one of the things I wanted to do
learn how to predict how peoples lives
transformed and changed across time and,
and what sort of Ma level
of achievement they manage.
So I was looking for the most
reliable and valid measures.
And it's clearly the psychometric
measures are the most reliable and valid
period.
No one disputes that.
So except like,
you know,
people in Women's studies
and that just doesn't count.
So you know,
they,
they don't have a methodology.
So,
so the fact that there's a
dispute just doesn't matter.
Yeah.
So
[inaudible] they have hypotheses,
right?
And then that's fine.
There's nothing wrong with
generating hypotheses.
Don't get me wrong,
there's nothing wrong with theory,
but when you start to
confuse theory with fact,
let's say,
then there's real trouble,
you know,
your theory has to be constructed,
at least in part so that you can make a
prediction of some sort so that you can
measure what your theory says that you
can measure and so that you can predict
something with it.
And then to see whether or
not your theory holds up.
Otherwise it's just
hypothesis and that's fine,
but you don't get to impose it on
everyone else because you get to state by
theater that your hypothesis is correct.
It's,
it's reprehensible to do that.
And,
and that's being done an awful lot,
an awful lot.
So I always found it interesting to think
about why there weren't any groups of
men that were trying to increase the
amount of men that were in nursing or
dental hygienists or education
or an education social work.
I always found that interesting.
I always,
and then I there lower pain disciplines.
MMM.
And then,
and then I recently started thinking
about this in terms of sports with the NFL
and NBA and I was like,
hmm,
there are just less Asian people
and Latino people and white people.
There's just,
there's more black people that artist
better athletes and are we going to
decrease?
Okay.
Standards for people have different from
eight that are Asian or Latino t to get
more primitive professional things.
He is funny
that,
that the,
the discussion about,
um,
gender differences in
occupational position,
let's say,
is unbelievably narrow.
You know,
it tends to focus on the
highest corporate positions.
That's not all of it,
but it tends to focus on the highest
corporate positions are the highest paid
positions.
But certainly it's quite interesting if,
if you're,
if you're into this sort of thing I
suppose to go online and just look up the
labor statistics from,
from the American federal
government because they,
they,
they rank order occupations by gender,
you know,
proportion and blood brick
layers or that's the,
that's the occupation that's
the most gender skewed.
There's like no female brick layers and,
but no one cares about that.
And it's kind of interesting.
Well,
no,
but it is interesting because it's not
like brick layers don't make a good
living,
you know,
like the skilled trades people
make a damn good living.
But heavy machinery operators,
very few women there too.
So,
but the percentage of work related deaths,
93% well that's a problem.
Yeah.
I mean that there's a bunch of reasons
why men make more money on average than
women do.
And one of them is that they're,
they're more willing to work outside.
That's when they're more willing to move.
That's another there.
They work longer hours and
if you worked 13% more hours,
you make 40% more money on that.
That's the stat.
So,
so that the effect of
overtime is nonlinear.
13% more hours.
40% more income.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well you can,
I think that's a good example of how,
you know,
let's say you have a bunch of employees
and you're trying to differentiate them
for promotion,
like,
and let's say they're all operating
within a relatively narrow band.
Perhaps they aren't,
but let's say for this example they are,
it's like,
well the person who
puts out 10% more self,
evidently so,
well this guy's around like 10% more.
That would be,
what about an extra 45 minutes a day,
something like that.
He goes the extra mile while
he's going to get the promotion.
And so you also get this,
like it also looks,
and this is worth thinking about too,
and this is part of the
predo distribution problem,
is that success is
disproportionately rewarded.
It's not linear.
So as you start to succeed,
the probe,
each success nonlinearly increases
the probability of the next success.
Right?
So the door's open.
Yeah,
we,
yeah,
that's right.
And not one door,
but they open exponentially.
Right?
Exactly.
And so,
and as you fail,
they close exponentially.
So you might think,
well,
failure,
success,
linear,
it's like no failure success,
right?
So once you start to fail,
good luck to you,
right?
Because each failure increases the
probability of the next failure in a
nonlinear mash fashion.
And that really,
if you're on a downhill trend,
man,
that's really vicious and
it's hard to get out of it.
You see that happen to big companies when
they start to go into a death spiral,
they can't pull themselves out of it.
But by the same token,
when you start to succeed,
each success increases
the probability of the next week.
You actually even see that with lobsters.
So back to the crustaceans.
Well,
they'd so interesting that some of these
things are so fundamental that they
appear so low in the file,
a genetic change.
So if you,
if you Kelly up,
you watch a lobster engaged in sequence,
sequential dominance dispute.
So basically physical challenges,
um,
his probability if he loses the problem,
if he loses the battle,
the probability that he'll lose the next
battle is higher than you would expect
if you just derived a linear function.
That was a consequence of the telly
of his previous victories and losses.
So because he's lost,
he's more likely to lose
harder the next time,
but if he wins,
he's statistically more likely to win.
So and,
and that also drives well that's a
fundamental issue to that drives the
disproportionate distribution of
productive goods and material resources,
which is a very big problem.
It's another thing to have an intelligent
discussion about in our Dev site.
Definitely we're going to get
there in this conversation as well.
So just before we wrap up the
point about big five and gender,
I have a thought about this
and it involves a company
that is very close to us
here in the bay area,
Google.
And the question about
Google is could it potentially be in the
interest of a company to want to bring
diverse people from around the world
in to increase the creativity of their
output?
It depends on how you define diverse,
but I would say you guys have
already done that in silicon valley.
It's like,
well how many people,
how many people in Silicon Valley or
from the Indian Institute of Technology?
It's like,
God,
they're everywhere.
You know,
and and no wonder while,
so that's,
but that's cognitive,
that's that's cognitive ability.
Like look is if there's someone that's
birth in a different part of the world
that has a different upbringing,
that could potentially
bring something unique,
a unique person.
There's no evidence for that whatsoever.
There's no,
there's no,
there's no evidence for that.
That is not how you get,
that's not the right
definition of diversity.
But could it also be potentially that we
are not measuring and focusing on that
in order to find that data?
No.
No,
it's not.
It's not because look,
measuring success is not an easy thing.
And you think it should be
meritocracy no matter what period.
No,
there's,
there's this,
there's always a fly in the ointment
there.
There is.
There's so the other thing,
there's a good book that I would recommend
reading called the great leveler by
Walter Shydel.
It's a new book,
relatively new book,
and he details out the,
he details out the erratic
ability of inequality.
So part of the problem with this process
that we just described where success
breeds success and failure breeds
failure,
is that the people who are succeeding
get a disproportionate share of the
resource pie,
let's say.
Um,
so you know,
everyone knows that about money,
right?
Because the 12 richest
people in the world,
85 richest people in the world have
as much money as the bottom 2 billion,
which seems while,
let's say unfair,
now,
it's certainly unequal.
Now whether it's I believe his Lord and
this statistic is the eight richest have
equal to the bottom 3.5 billion.
Yeah,
well I think it's probably worse than
it was when I looked at this about three
years ago.
So,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't matter cause you,
you,
you get the point.
But it's not crazy.
But the thing is is that this is not
something that only applies to money.
It applies to everything
that's creatively produced.
So the same rule applies to number
of records sold by recording artists.
The same rule applies to number
of books sold by novelists.
The same rule applies to number of
goals scored by Nhl hockey players.
The same rule applies to the population
of cities and the massive stars and the
size of trees in the,
in the jungle.
It's like the inequality problem is
way more troublesome again then mere
capitalism,
it's a terrible problem
and Shydel is work,
which is really,
really interesting.
He's traced back inequality
10 15,000 years using,
you can do it for example,
let's say you find a Neolithic burial
site and there's 200 people in it,
so these people would be buried with
their possessions and obviously some of
them decay,
but some of them don't.
And like some of them
are buried with gold.
Well hardly any of them.
And the tiny proportion of people who
are born bird with gold are burned with a
lot of gold.
So you can even drive a
Gini Coefficient estimate,
which is an estimate of
inequality from burial sites.
And it looks like as soon
as you get a surplus,
you get inequality.
And that's a rough thing
because you might think,
well even in hunter gatherer
societies where there's no surplus,
there's still inequality cause
there's inequality of friendship,
there's inequality of health and
there's inequality of sexual access.
And those things are,
they are not trivial.
But when you're thinking
about it purely economically,
you start to get an inequality.
As soon as you get a surplus you think,
oh that's interesting.
So there's a natural rule which
is surplus generates inequality.
All right,
so how do you solve that?
And Shy Dell's book says,
well that's easy.
You just get rid of the surplus.
Right?
And that's not good.
So like he,
he found and so one of the things
he did was statistical analysis.
Cause one of the things he might ask is,
well let's say you have your measures of
inequality and then you can track them
around the world and you can track whether
or not the inequality is generated by
a right wing government
or a left wing government.
And then you might hope,
well the left wing governments
would ameliorate inequality.
There's no evidence for that at all.
It doesn't look like
inequality is with it.
It doesn't look like the amelioration
of inequality is within the purview of
political organization.
And you should like,
you should not hear that with any degree
of happiness whatsoever because the
social science on inequality is also
clear as inequality levels increase,
society's destabilize.
And the best indicator of that,
I already mentioned that that
was work that was done by
Martin Daly and Margo Wilson at
McMaster university in Canada.
They're really interested in what drove
male homicide because most homicide is
male,
male on male.
It's mostly young males.
It's mostly within race and
it's mostly status competition,
right?
So,
and the status competitions get
intense where inequality increases.
So where everyone's poor.
So if you rank order American states
and Canadian provinces by inequality,
the poor provinces where everyone's poor,
there's no male aggression and the rich
provinces and states where everyone's
rich,
there's no male male homicide,
but the states and provinces
where inequality is high,
the male homicide rates starts to climb
up and it's probably the most aggressive
males who get most aggressive most
rapidly when inequality increases.
So there's a psychological component,
but inequality drives male
homicide 0.9 is the correlation,
which means that you actually don't
need any other explanation for male
homicide.
Maybe you throw in alcohol just just as a,
as an extraneous variable.
You don't need any other explanation for
the male homicide rate than inequality.
It's a staggering work.
It's absolutely staggering work.
And so the,
the thing is is that a meritocracy will
drive inequality and then you have a
problem because people stack up at
zero and they can't get out of zero.
Cause that's what happens
as inequality increases.
People think about when
you're playing monopoly,
you know the game.
I mean that's a perfect example
of how inequality emerges.
Everybody's equal to begin with.
Everybody basically plays a random game
because monopolies basically a random
game.
I mean there's some skill in it,
but not much so.
So it's a random game.
So what happens when everyone starts
equal and you play a random game?
One person ends up with everything.
Everyone else stacks up at zero.
Now shy Dell's book basically shows the
only way out of that is various forms of
war,
including revolution.
And epidemics.
That's it.
That's the only thing he's
been able to track that.
And,
and what happens is when you level
everyone and then inequality decreases,
it's like,
well,
okay,
that doesn't seem like
a really great solution.
[inaudible] and this seems to be
even more and more pressing with the
proliferation of artificial intelligence,
robotics,
genetic engineering,
neuroprosthetics,
nanotechnology,
and the race between China and the
United States and Russia colonizing Mars.
What is going,
how do we actually end up coming to a
global consensus on what to do as eight
people equate and wealth to the bottom 12.
I don't see why we have to
have an intelligent discussion
about this because on
the one hand,
it's pretty obvious that modern economies
are doing a damn good job of lifting
people rapidly out of abject poverty.
Okay.
But at the same time,
the inequality of,
of the economic inequality
by some measures at least
is increasing and that does
have this destabilizing effect.
And so then the question is what,
what do you do about it?
Well,
it's really hard because in a meritocracy,
part of that's driven by,
um,
segregation by intelligence.
And then that's likely exaggerated by
the provision of computational power
because it really smart person with a
computer is way smarter than a really
smart person without a computer and is
and is way smarter than a person who
isn't so smart either with
or without a computer.
Right?
So the computational technology
looks like it's a multiplier.
Like I'm sure many of you already know
now because there's a huge difference
between someone who can really use a
computer and someone who's barely computer
literate and lots of way more people are
barely computer literate literate than
you know.
So here's a good stat.
This is like,
I'm really familiar,
I've really familiarized myself with
the ICU literature and had said dismal,
horrible literature.
But,
but you really need to know it because
it's a solid literature unfortunately.
And um,
one of the most terrifying statistics I
ever came across was one detailing out
the rationale of the United States Armed
Forces for not allowing the induct.
You can't induct anyone into the armed
forces in the US if they have an Iq of
less than 83.
Okay.
So let's just take that apart for a
minute because it's a horrifying thing.
So the US armed forces has been in the
forefront of intelligence research since
World War One because they were on board
early with the idea that especially
during war time when you're ramping up
quickly that you need to sort people
effectively and essentially without
prejudice so that you can build up the
officer corps so you
don't lose the damn war.
Okay.
So there's real motivation
to get it right,
right.
Cause it's life and death issue.
So they used Iq,
they did a lot of the early
psychometric work on Iq.
Okay.
So that's the first thing.
They're,
they're motivated to find
an accurate predictor.
So they settled on Iq.
The second thing was the United States
armed forces also really motivated to get
people into the armed forces.
Peace time or war time or time.
Well for obvious reasons,
peace time because,
well first of all you got to
keep the armed forces going.
And second,
you can use the armed forces during peace
time as a way of taking people out of
the underclass and moving them up into
the working class or the middle class.
Right?
You can use it as a
training mechanism and,
and so there's left and right.
Can agree on that.
You know,
it's,
it's a reasonable way of
promoting social mobility.
So again,
the armed forces,
even in peace time is very motivated to
get as many people in as they possibly
can.
And it's difficult as well.
It's not that easy to recruit people,
so you don't want to throw
people out if you don't have to.
So what's the upshot of all that?
While after a hundred years
essentially of of statistic,
careful statistical analysis,
the armed forces concluded that
if you had an Iq of 83 or less,
there wasn't anything you could possibly
be trained to do in the military at any
level of the organization that
wasn't positively counterproductive.
Okay.
You think,
well,
so what,
83 okay.
Yeah.
One in 10,
one in 10 that's one in 10 people.
And that what that really means that as
far as I can tell is if you imagine that
the military is approximately as
complex as the broader society,
which I think is a reasonable proposition,
then there's no place in our cognitively
complex society for one in 10 people.
So what are we going to do about that?
The answer is no one knows.
Say well shovel money down the hierarchy.
It's like the problem isn't lack of money.
I mean sometimes that's the problem,
but the problem is
rarely absolute poverty.
It's rarely that it is sometimes,
but rarely.
It's not that easy to move
money down the hierarchy.
So first of all,
it's not that easy to manage money.
So it's a vicious problem,
man.
And so it's hard to train
people to become creative,
adaptive problem solvers as possible.
You can do it,
you cannot do it.
You can interfere with
their conquerors ability,
but you can't.
You can't do that.
It's training doesn't work.
It's not as well as six months,
but it could work in six years.
No,
it doesn't work.
Sorry.
It doesn't work like the data on.
That's crystal clear as well.
Look,
I can give you an example.
So I knew a bunch of people who run MBA
programs and I've had discussions with
them because the thing about
an MBA program is it's,
if it's selective,
it's really hard to get in.
It's like getting into Harvard.
It's really hard to get into Harvard.
You have to have an Iq that places
you at least at the 99th percentile,
and then you have to be really good
at at least one or two other things.
So it's really hard to get in.
Okay,
so you think,
well,
why hire a Harvard graduate?
Well,
it's the quality of the education.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
It's the fact that it's
really hard to get it.
All of the value of the Ivy League
education is in the screening before the,
before the,
uh,
before the education starts.
Now that doesn't mean that people,
people go to Harvard
and they get educated,
but they'd get just as educated
if they went somewhere else.
First of all,
it's like every university contains more
information than any student can ever
possibly process.
If you're super smart,
you can be dropped into a state college.
Some are low level state college,
he's spending four years in the library,
you know,
like what,
what are you going to do?
Read the whole library.
No,
right.
So,
so in the data on this is quite clear.
It's like,
and it's the same with private schools.
The reason that people who go to private
schools do better than people who go to
public schools is because
generally speaking,
the people who go into
private schools are smarter.
It's not the education that's any better.
And so we radically overestimate
the degree to which training works.
So now you can train people to be stupid.
That's,
but training them to be smarter
than they are is really,
really,
really hard.
So like I said,
it's a dismal literature.
And Liberals see the liberals think
everyone's roughly equal and there's a job
for everyone.
You just have to train them.
It's like no wrong.
And the Conservatives think,
well,
there's
a job for everyone if they just
get off their ass and work.
It's like,
no,
that's wrong too.
Even though if you work,
that's better.
And well,
so that's on the conservative end,
but the liberals won't take into account
individual differences while obviously
that's part of what the whole
politically correct discussion is about.
It's like everyone's the same.
It's like,
yeah.
Um,
they're not,
you don't want to find it.
It's really,
it's really annoying.
I would say like,
I love,
love,
love to come to silicon valley.
I've been here many,
many times and like it's really
something to come here and,
and,
and meet.
There's so many people here who off
the scales intelligence and they're all
clustered together,
which is why this place is so unbelievably
rich and so unbelievably productive.
One of the reasons,
but it's very,
it's also very annoying that it's so left
leaning because one of the things that
the left leaning Silicon Valley geniuses
should understand that is that they're
the beneficiary of a genetic lottery
and they should take that seriously.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
You worked hard.
Yes.
Your entrepreneurial.
You're on point.
You put into your 60 hours a week,
you know,
you do everything you could do.
You have an Iq of 150 and
like that's not your doing,
right?
That's something that happened to you.
And so you can't be saying,
well,
it's,
it's all me.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
It's all you and the genius
that you were granted as a,
as an infant.
It's,
that's it.
That's what's driving it.
Now that doesn't mean I think that
people have disproportionate intelligence
shouldn't be rewarded disproportionately.
It's possible that they should because
it might be in the best interest of
everyone else to dump as much money as
possible to the top 2% of the cognitive
strata because they're going
to be most generative with it.
And so,
and even if it's not fair,
because you might say,
well,
just because he won the genetic lottery,
does that mean that you should
have more money than anyone else?
It's like,
well,
not on the grounds of fairness,
but if you have to distribute money while
who are you going to distribute it to?
You know,
and I think ti was it Ted who ran CNN,
Ted Turner,
he estimated that if you tried as
hard as you could in your entire life,
there was no way that you could
spend more than $400 million.
And so like let's say you have more
money than that at your disposal,
well hopefully you're going to do some
halfways intelligent things with it.
And hopefully you would expect that the
more intelligent people would do more
than halfway intelligent things with it.
So if you have to have
unequal distribution than a
meritocracy is probably the
best way to do it.
But it still leaves you
with this terrible problem,
which is what do you do with all
the people who stack up at zero?
And the answer isn't have contempt for
them because they don't work as hard as
you.
It's like,
yeah,
a bunch of them don't,
you know,
because conscientiousness
also predicts success.
So among the poor,
there are people who don't work,
you know,
but you never want to underestimate
the contribution of cognitive ability.
So it's rough,
man,
and we don't take it seriously and
we don't know what to do about it.
And yet it's clear that
as inequality increases,
society's destabilized.
That's clear.
So it's something that
has to be dealt with and,
but we don't know how to deal with it.
We don't know how to efficiently move
resources to the bottom end of the
competence hierarchy so that
things don't destabilize.
So,
you know,
and I've worked with people,
lots of people who are,
who are at the bottom end of the
hierarchy in my clinical practice.
And you know,
like cocaine addicts for example,
low [inaudible],
low Iq,
cocaine addicts,
not,
not all cocaine addicts
have low Iq by the way.
But you know,
it's,
it's just,
uh,
it's,
it's a triple whammy,
let's say.
Cause if you're a cocaine addict,
you probably also an alcoholic.
And so if you're a cocaine addict and
you're an alcoholic and you're sort of on
the low end of the cognitive distribution,
it's like you have pretty damn rough life.
There's a lot of things
going wrong for you.
And you're really lucky if you're flat
broke because as soon as you get money,
you are so done,
you cannot believe it.
So like when your unemployment check
comes in and you're a cocaine addict,
alcoholic who isn't employed,
the probability that three days later
you're going to end up face down in the
ditch is really,
really high.
So don't be thinking like,
it's not so simple that you can just dump
money down the competence hierarchy to
the,
to the people who are in the underclass
and expect that that's going to have a
salutary effect.
I don't think there's any
evidence for that whatsoever.
It's like money is not an easy
resource to use productively.
So is a class based speciation
something to be concerned about?
Um,
elaborate on that a little bit.
What do you mean exactly?
Well by class based speciation,
meaning there's already a
tremendous amount of wealth
that is accumulated within
such a small percentage of people and
whether it be through a bifurcation of
split of a couple billion people off
of the human species or it could be a
trifurcation.
We don't know how many
splits there may be,
whether that,
I don't know if it's something to worry
about or something to hope for it.
I mean this timescales are so large
that it's probably not relevant to
individuals potentially something to hope
for in the evolutionary trajectory of
the human.
Well you kind of hope
that people get smarter.
My might get smarter across time.
I guess we would hope that
might be a good thing.
I mean it's not self evident so,
so if it is a lottery,
if it was a roll of the dice
to be born where we are,
don't we also feel that it could have
been rolled the dice to be born in a place
less fortunate therefore sure.
We do feel that.
I think that's why the didn't even know.
Even if you're successful,
people often feel guilty
because of inequality and say,
no wonder your ultimate calling in
terms of the width of religion and with,
uh,
with finding self actualization and
meaning within us to what you say,
eradicate suffering is something
that is give so much meaning to life.
Well,
the,
sometimes people in less
fortunate circumstances
experienced lots of suffering
with lack of food or water or
shelter or basic physiological needs.
And so then therefore,
doesn't it feel like within this potential
class-based speciation with wealth
that there should be some
sort of assistant course?
Of course.
Okay.
And now the conversation
is how can we do that?
So there's a couple of things there.
I mean,
to the degree,
like you know,
I've been a vocal opponent
of the radical left and I,
I,
I can't detest them enough really.
Is this a fundamental,
is the fund my fundamental position?
But
that doesn't mean that
I don't think that uh,
functioning polity requires
a left and a right wing.
Absolutely.
And the reason it requires a left wing
is because inequality is real and it has
to be addressed.
It has to be addressed for all
the reasons that you described,
but,
but
having said that,
there are ways to go about addressing it
that are clearly counterproductive and
those were tried to great destructive
power in the 20th century and I don't
really think we need to do that again.
The corollary to that is we don't know
what the productive means are now.
I've been thinking a lot about that,
you know,
and I'm thinking,
well,
how do you solve the
problem of inequality?
And it has to be something like the moral
burden on those who are successful has
to be increased.
It's something like that.
And I think you see that,
I mean,
I think I wrote this to you,
that what's the significance of
purchasing a third yacht rather than maybe
hiring 50 people to solve
a problem in the world?
It's hard.
These things aren't so simple.
You know,
like let's say that you decided to go
out to a restaurant and your meal is $500
and you might think,
well that's reprehensible and well,
perhaps you don't think
that's reprehensible.
But the thing is,
it's not a bad way of
dispersing extra money.
So it's not that obvious what rich
people should do with their money that's
beneficial.
And you think,
well,
should you buy a third yard
because do you really need it?
And well,
that's particularly perhaps a
particularly egregious example,
but it's not like you're not
employing people when you do that.
You shouldn't stuff the
money in your mattress.
We could say that,
right.
Because that's just pure hoarding.
But most people who have money
aren't like scrooge McDuck.
They don't have a money been
that they swim in right there.
Money.
Well that's,
that's the kind of,
that's the kind of
clueless picture of wealth.
I mean,
most people who have money,
their money is out there doing things.
It's not like they're,
it's not like it's in their bedroom,
you know,
and,
and in gold coin form.
So they're not hoarding it in exactly
the same way that perhaps people used to
hoard wealth when it
wasn't as abstracted and,
and,
and functional in its own terms
out there in the aquarium.
Money is usually working for them,
making them more money.
Yeah.
But it's also doing a
bunch of other things.
You know?
And if you're a bad money manager,
even if you're wealthy,
you're money tends to
disappear very rapidly.
That's another thing that's really worth
knowing is that like there is a 1% and
that 1% does have a disproportionate
amount of the money and 1% of that 1% has
an even more disproportionate
amount of the money.
It's scales all the way up the up
the measurement spectrum let's say,
but there's actually quite a bit of
mobility within that 1% so you have a 10%
chance in your lifetime in the United
States of being in the top 1% for at least
a year.
Now that's not like a
hundred percent chance,
but it's one in 10 it's not dismal,
you know,
so well,
partly what you hope for is that
there's some genuine upward mobility.
But then I think the other thing that
you hope for is that people who are
disproportionately successful take it
upon themselves to do everything they
possibly can to do whatever they can.
That's the best possible
thing to do with their money.
And you know,
I'm kind of an admirer of Bill
Gates for a variety of reasons,
but he's doing a really good job of
putting the boots to the five world,
the world's five worst
transmissible diseases.
You know,
and that's going quite nicely.
they're making some real
polios just about defunct.
They're making some real
progress with malaria.
Like there's almost nothing that can be
possibly be done for Africa that would
be more useful than to get rid of malaria.
Sleeping sickness would be another one
that would be really useful to allow to
eradicate.
And so I would say that
the longterm solution,
assuming that there is one,
two,
the problem of inequality is that people
who are disproportionately fortunate,
let's say,
or successful or both take it upon,
take the moral duty of doing the best
possible good that they can with the money
that they generate.
But the other thing I think that's sort
of interesting about that is I actually
don't think there's anything
more interesting to do with
your money that direct.
It's like,
can you think of anything more interesting
to do with your money than to find a
really difficult problem that causes a
bunch of people suffering and then try to
fix it?
It's like amazing.
If you have a clue that's gotta be
a little better than a third yacht.
Yeah.
So yeah,
no,
it's pretty low.
Well,
it's kind of a low bar like
that conspicuous consumption
thing at at some point
it's just if you have any sense at some
point that's just not very impressive.
Could it could.
Another way to address the potential
class based speciation be the education of
the child and by the principles of let's
say that over the last hundred billion
people that have lived in died to build
this beautiful world we live in today
with all of the food and water ubiquity
and the governments and the economies
that there,
every child that's being stamped out
into this world might have a little tiny
missing chip on their shoulder and that
missing chip might be things like their
parents explaining to them what
evolution is or what their anatomy,
what their heart and their brain is,
their body may be,
what morality is,
things like that.
If maybe every child is born with a
little bit of something like that.
Do you think there's
something like that Jordan?
Yeah.
This,
you know like that's done right?
This thing is connecting everyone to
everything and so the probability that
people are going to be get
whatever education they
want in the next 30 years is
overwhelmingly high.
So I think in some sense
that problem is being solved as
rapidly as it can possibly be.
Be being solved.
That is,
it doesn't mean people should stop trying
to find more and more effective ways
of educating.
I think that would be reading some general
basic principles that you think of.
Parents should teach a child
obviously within the rules of life,
but it may be something about evolution
or something about their own anatomy and
well,
I think that,
I think that there are all sorts of
things that parents who are good parents
teach their children.
I mean,
part of what 12 rules for
life is about is about that.
It's like a universal
ethic in some sense there.
I think that there is a,
there's dawning realization among
members of the biologically oriented
community.
Let's say that there is something like
an emergent ethic that's evident in
biological systems and um,
one of the most outstanding examples of
that I would say is apart from the work
that dwell has done with chimpanzees,
showing the beginnings of an ethic,
at least in in the behavioral sense,
the beginnings of an ethic among
chimpanzees is work that's being done with
rats.
And so Jaak Panksepp for example,
who wrote a book called
an affect of neuroscience,
which I would highly recommend.
It's a real work of genius.
You blew my mind with Piaget,
by the way,
with the way that rats,
no,
that's Panksepp know.
Piaget found out,
found out that out in children.
So,
oh,
Panksepp was a scientist who
discovered that rats laugh.
It's hurting and you think,
well that's not a big deal.
It's like actually it is a really big
deal because it shows that it shows
commonality of the positive emotion
systems across biological strata
essentially.
So it's actually a really big deal.
And he found that if you
tickle routes with an Eraser,
they laugh ultrasonically and so you
have to slow it down to hear them.
And the reason he figured figure that
out was because he was trying to figure
out why.
If you take rat pups away from their
mother and feed them and give them enough
water,
they still die.
They die unless you massage them
with while he used a pencil eraser.
That's what cause it's Kinda soft and
it seems to work without harming the
routes.
A little rap pops in.
If you rub them with pencil racer,
then they'll thrive.
And that was actually translated very
rapidly into practical research because it
turns out that if you
have a premature infant,
it's an incubator.
They often lose weight a,
which is a really bad thing because
they're supposed to be gaining weight.
But if you massage them three
times a day for 10 minutes,
then they'll gain weight about
as fast as they do in utero.
And they leave the hospital
on average five days earlier.
And the beneficial cognitive
and physiological effects
are still detectable six
months down the road to walloping.
It's a walloping effect.
And so it turns out that one of the
things Panksepp sorted out was that human
that touches a human need.
It's not a secondary need.
It's a primary need.
Like like food and water
and childhood development.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well.
And then he was also a big proponent of
rough and tumble play because he found
out that in routes that
rough and tumble play,
especially among juvenile males,
catalyzes prefrontal development and
that rat pups who are male that aren't
allowed to engage in
rough and tumble play,
she'll prefrontal hypo development and
you can then treat them with Ritalin,
which is the Adhd drug,
just in case you're wondering.
So that's a very dismal
line of scientific research,
but also very promising.
So what Panksepp also found,
and this is another piece of information
that really blew me away when I first
first read about it,
was so he,
he,
he Panksepp discovered the place,
circuitry and mammals.
And that's also a big deal,
right?
That's like discovering a continent to
discover a dedicated circuitry to a set
of complex biological functions.
That's a big deal,
man.
And so,
um,
when he was investigating
play behavior among rats,
he noticed that juvenile males in
particular would work to wrestle.
And they wrestle really a lot.
Like,
well,
human children or like cumin children
and dogs wrestle and rats pin each other.
So,
um,
what banks have found first was that,
and other scientists as well,
but I'll use him as a shorthand,
was that rats would work to enter a play
arena where they knew they were going
to be allowed to wrestle with a appear.
And that's kind of how you figure out
if a rat wants to do something right,
you make them button press forward or
pull on something and then you can measure
how fast you'll press the button or
how hard it pull and you can get some
estimate of how motivated he is.
Routes are pretty damn motivated
to enter into a play arena.
And so if one route enters into a player
arena and another rat does and the one
rat is 10% bigger than the other,
then in like nine out of 10 cases,
the big rat can pin the little rat
and in the first bout then pinning,
establish his dominance.
This is kind of an interesting
commentary on scientific methodology too,
because let's say that you
are investigating rat behavior
and you were trying to
draw conclusions and you
only paired rats together.
Once you'd assume the big rat dominates
its physical size that does the
domination and that's the purpose of play.
But that isn't right because it's like
don't let it win play as something that
iterates,
right?
You don't play with a person
only once you play with them.
Well who knows for how long,
right?
If it's a relationship that lasts decades,
then it's decades of
reciprocal interaction.
So Panksepp and his colleagues and the
other scientists who are working on this
paired the rats repeatedly.
So these are iterated games and the rules
of an iterated game aren't the same as
the rules of a one off game.
And that might actually be the basis
for a universal ethic is that there are
rules for iterated games.
And what paths have found was that,
okay,
so the big rat is now super
ordinate to the little rat.
Now when you repair them,
the little rat has to ask
the big let route to play.
That's the rule.
So the big rat gets
to sit there like he's cool and
the little rat cast to hop up like,
like a dog that's asking you to
play and sort of bounce around.
You all know what that looks like.
Dog kind of puts its
rear end up in the air,
kind of hops a little bit.
And that means like,
well come on human cuff me,
you know and if you have any sense,
you know how to do that and you can even
understand when a dog does it and the
dog,
if he socialized can understand
when you're doing it right
cause well socialized
dog is you Kinda,
you kinda go like this and then he does
the same thing and you whack them on the
side of the head little bit
and he growls and puts his,
you know your hand in his
mouth but he doesn't bite it.
But he sounds like he's going to,
the dog knows what the hell is
going on unless it's completely,
unless it's raised by a
behavioral psychologist,
which isn't
the worst behaved dog I ever saw was
the dog that was raised by a behavioral
psychologist.
So anyway,
sorry about that.
But so anyway,
so the pair of these rats together
and what you find is that,
so the little rat has to ask the
big rat to play in the big rattle,
like you know,
break is cool and then wrestle.
And then if you pair them repeatedly,
unless the big rat lets the little rat
win 30% of the time for little rat will
no longer ask him to play.
Like I read that it was like a little
electrical storm went off in my bag is
what happened to me too.
Well,
it's so good.
So on.
So absolutely unbelievable is that,
well there you have this
emergent ethic of reciprocity.
All you need to do is pair animals
together in reciprocal play boats and you
have an emergent reciprocity
and then you think,
well,
okay,
so that's the basis for social
interaction is that reciprocity.
There's a bit of an advantage to the,
to the big rat,
but not a huge advantage.
Say,
well that's the beginning of an ethic.
And you say,
well,
human beings that efficacy merged at the
biological level and then human beings
watched it develop and
told stories about it.
That's where the stories came from.
And then out of the stories we coded
and explicit ethic and that's where the
philosophy of ethics came from.
But it emerged from the bottom up.
Something Nietzsche
predicted like 150 years ago.
He said,
well,
you know,
we'll find that there was an emergent
ethic that emerged biologically and then
was later mapped.
And so that was just,
wow,
that's just absolutely beyond belief
and then very likely true and points the
way to something like
while in archetipal ethics,
certainly one of reciprocity,
which,
uh,
which I think the fundamental
art archetypical ethic,
it's like,
well,
here's another example,
Jordan.
Maybe just because we,
when we will not touch
on a bunch of other,
uh,
points as well.
We've,
we're,
we're amazingly in depth in this.
This is so cool.
While universal ethic is
important as it turns out.
Exactly.
Let me tell just a brief story.
Okay.
All right.
Because this is also,
this is also extremely important
because it shows where the classical
economists,
brief story,
brief,
brief Jordan Peterson.
Yeah,
I know,
I know.
It's not likely.
So let's play a trading game.
Okay,
so you two can play this trading game.
So here's the deal.
It's very simple.
I'm going to give you $100.
I'm not actually,
but I'm going to give you $100 and you
can offer some of it to your partner in
the game.
But the rule is if she says no,
you don't get anything and neither does
she and you only get to make one offer.
So okay,
here's your hundred dollars.
How much you can offer her?
40 okay.
Would you take 40 okay then
now that's interesting.
Okay,
very good.
That's perfect.
Okay,
so first of all,
the classic economic economist would
say you should offer her a dollar.
Why?
Well,
because she might as well take a dollar
cause she gets a dollar and you want to
maximize your own return.
So you get $99 it's like
what happens when you do that?
What happens is that is
never what people do.
They usually offer approximately
50% and if they don't,
then the other person refuses.
Yeah.
Now then you might think,
well,
let's say matched a rich person,
a poor person,
and you said,
okay,
give the rich person a hundred and
they offer the poor person a dollar.
What is the poor person say?
You think,
well,
yeah,
I need the dollar.
It's they say,
no,
go to hell.
I'm not doing it because,
and they're more likely the poor person
is more likely to refuse the lower offer
than a rich person is completely running
completely contrary to the predictions
of classical economists.
You played that game across the world.
It's pretty much 50 50 and I,
that's so interesting because it's
another example of that emergent ethic.
It's like,
well,
part of the reason you'd say no and why
no was correct is because you don't play
one trading game.
You play a lifetime of trading games and
the right answer to the question of how
to play a lifetime of trading games is
to not settle for less than 50% money.
You could also make a case that if
you're the giver rather than receiver,
if you're playing an iterated game,
you might want to offer $60 $60 because
especially if your reputation is being
broadcast,
because let's say your goal isn't to get
$40 which is what you'd be left if you
offered 60 your goal is to let everybody
know that if they play with you,
you give them 60 and you get 40
and then what happens is like,
well let's take a vote on
who wants to play with who.
It's like you want to play with the person
who offers the a 10 or do you want to
play with the person who offers you 60
and then the person who's a little more
generous than reciprocal.
You know,
50 50 would be reciprocal.
Maybe you should err on
the side of generosity.
Why easily easy people will
line up to play with you.
So then the question is,
do you want to win the game or do
you want to win the set of games?
Right.
And I think,
I think there's rules that govern the
set of all possible games and it's the
rules that govern the set of all possible
games that constitutes something like
an emergent ethic.
So anyway,
so that's a very useful thing to know.
It's a very useful thing to know.
It is.
Can you give a couple quick ones of
those potentially universal ethics that
govern the set of games?
Well,
I think,
I think that's the big one.
I think.
I think the big one is you
approximate reciprocity,
but it would be better.
It'd be better if you
can figure out how to,
I think you,
it's recept reciprocity with erring on
the side of generosity because there's
just no downside to that.
In an iterated game.
It's like,
I'm going to borrow what I do when I
grade papers with students for example,
is I grade them and
then I had 5% it's like,
well,
maybe I made a mistake.
So I'll err on the side of generosity.
Right.
And why not do that in your
reciprocal interactions.
That doesn't mean you're letting
people take advantage of you,
right?
It's not a matter of weakness in your
negotiating strategy because there's no
excuse for that.
That's just,
that's a losing game that,
but if you could take 50% or 70%
and you decide to be generous,
it's like,
well,
you still have to be awake so that you're
not being messed about with by people
who are a little bit on the
psychopathic and you know,
you don't want to be foolish about it,
but reciprocal plus generous.
That's a hell of a good start.
So can we do quick dive into
science and God because I want,
I want to know and quick
let's,
let's try.
So let's try
10 science sufficiently,
consistently self actualize humans.
Well,
okay.
Let cause with,
with your,
with God,
with religion people find some
sort of self actualization.
10 science be a source of self
actualization or morality.
The way that we normally construe science.
Like if you look at,
let,
let's make that concrete for,
for a minute.
Um,
when,
when I teach my students my personality
class and we concentrated a fair bit on
clinical theories because I'm a clinician,
one of the things I make clear to them
is that neither medicine nor clinical
psychology,
our sciences,
they're there,
they're variants of engineering.
They're attempting to build something.
There's an end in mind.
There's an ethical end in mind,
right?
I mean,
what you do when you're a
clinical psychologist is try
to help people make their
lives better.
Or you might say,
well,
you're trying to make them
more mentally healthy,
but actually that's a weaker description
then that you're trying to make their
lives better.
Because sometimes as a
clinical psychologist,
you see people who are,
you know,
they're normal in their health,
but they would like
their lives to be better.
There's an op obviously there,
but,
and that introduces the ethical realm
and you might be able to use scientific
techniques in order to determine which
of the strategies you use to try to make
your life better are working.
But it's not obvious that you can use
scientific principles to decide what
constitutes better to begin with.
It's a big problem.
I don't see any evidence that you can,
well,
how about just science,
science,
morality from its purview
at the methodological level?
Well,
okay,
let's take an example of cancer and
science solving suffering by providing
solutions to cancer.
Yeah.
Well,
should you devote money
to cancer education?
That's,
see,
that's where the problems start
to come is that you can't,
you can't make an a priori decisions.
You can't make an informed
decision about where the ethical,
where the scientific
attention should focus itself.
It's not an easy thing to do.
At some point,
the decisions have to be there,
either arbitrary,
they're made by,
they're made by techniques that seem to
be outside of the scientific purview.
Let me give you an example.
So I read this book by an ex KGB agent
who had detailed out some of the extent
of the Soviet,
uh,
biological warfare
program back in the 1980s.
And one of the things the
Soviet scientists were trying
to do according to this
guy was to weaponize,
um,
biological infectious biological agents
actually turns out to be harder than we
suspected,
thank God.
And,
um,
what they were trying to do was cross
smallpox with Ebola and it's because Ebola
is like seriously fatal and
smallpox is seriously contagious.
And so they thought,
well,
seriously fatal plus seriously contagious.
It's like what could be better than that?
Right?
Right.
And so,
and he might say,
well is crossing Ebola with smallpox if
is seeing whether you can cross Ebola
with smallpox,
reasonable scientific question and
appropriate scientific question and purely
from the perspective of science,
yes,
science is a generic
problem solving mechanism.
Now you might say,
well no,
it's like it's not something
any reasonable human being
should ever engage in.
But that's not the same thing as asking
whether or not it's a question within
the reasonable purview of science.
I mean the thing about science is that
science was designed to be as value free
a methodology as possible.
It's designed for that.
And so then people say,
well why is there a gap
between science and values?
It's like,
well,
because it's built into the methodology.
So it looks to me like you need something
that's outside of science to direct
the,
the ethic.
And it seems to me that
something like stories,
what can come from within science,
I don't see how,
I mean partly because it's,
it just glued the value.
Isn't the story of the cosmos already
enough to get someone excited enough to
find some sort of value system from the
being born from the stars and that being
inspirational?
No,
not necessarily.
Because you can just as easily say,
well,
you know,
here we are in this little
dirt ball in the middle,
you know,
and the outer edge of this
galaxy that's rotating,
going to rotate pointlessly
for the next 250 million years,
you know,
a couple of dozen billion years
before the heat death of the universe.
It's like that's pretty dismal
accounting of the utility of life.
I mean,
you know what I mean?
You can take you sure to hear
what you have that entire,
you have that entire range of
interpretive possibilities from like,
isn't life remarkable
and wonderful and too,
isn't it bloody pointless if you,
if you look at it from
the wrong temporary,
I can find that from science.
Well.
Yeah,
but you can also find the reverse.
So that's the problem.
I'm not anti scientific,
but I don't,
I don't see a simple way
of solving the problem of,
of,
of the ethical direction
of the scientific inquiry.
I mean you don't do it.
What comes to mind maybe as
a way to to get to that area?
Well,
one of the things that I talked
about in detail with Sam Harris,
and we're going to talk about this some
more because it's by no means solved is
the relationship between facts
and values and the old idea,
Hume's ideas,
you can't derive values
from a set of fact.
And I think that's sort of right.
But I do,
I kind of think it's more
complicated than Hume thought it was,
but I'm not exactly sure why because
like I made a case earlier about this
emergent ethic arising out of out
of out of eight are rated games.
That kind of looks like a scientific
observation about the origin of morality
and something like that.
So it's not like science can't
inform your moral decisions,
but exactly how that might come about
is by no means a straight forward issue.
And I mean,
well it's also not the case.
It is also not self evident that science
has served a beneficial function for
human beings.
Like it might be the case,
it could be the case.
I mean,
look,
we're pretty comfortable here and thank
God and that's definitely a consequence
of the scientific revolution.
But,
but you know,
highlighted your phone as a major,
but one good hydrogen bomb blown up over
North America would set us back about
50,000 years.
And that could easily happen
if I was a paranoid dictator.
That's certainly what I would do.
And I know you,
I don't know,
most of you guys probably know what would
happen if you blow up a hydrogen bomb.
I think it's about 150 miles up,
something like that.
One,
you get an electromagnetic pulse,
it takes all the electronics out,
like all of them,
right?
One bomb.
And so like maybe we'll manage that,
but it wouldn't.
And you know,
maybe we'll manage that transition
to whatever we're going to do next,
but I wouldn't count on it.
And so it isn't even necessarily the
case that scientific endeavor is a pro
human life process and
he's in what we do with it.
I suppose that's why you said earlier
that it's important now more than ever to
have these conversations about the future
of humanity and where are we going?
How are we going to do this together?
So let,
let's,
let's talk about just ending
it off with mutual exploration.
I really thought this was interesting
and the intellectual dark web is a really
good example of this,
which you are a main pillar
of a,
in my opinion.
So let's say that two people are having
a conversation and they're reducing
their points.
There may be keeping it
to a straight binary.
We see a lot of political polarization
that's occurring today and United States
politics finding a lot of the beauty
and the nuance of conversation when you
take complex position and you may be
stay economists rather than become
agitated.
Um,
all of these things tend to
drive better conversations.
And it seems as though you're
leading that forefront.
What what,
what do you see in that sort of path
that we're walking of figuring out how to
have better conversations?
There's a,
I write about this a fair
bit and 12 rules for life.
There's a chapter,
I think it's chapter nine.
I think that's right.
Assuming that the person that you're
listening to know something you don't,
it's kind of a derivation of some of some
things that I learned from Carl Rogers
who was a great clinician,
great 20th century clinician,
his star sort of rose during
the 1960s he was a humanist,
he was a Christian
missionary when he was a kid,
but he dropped that and he became a
leading light humanistic psychology and he
was really interested in the preconditions
for therapeutic conversation and he
thought that,
well,
if you are going to engage in the
process of therapy with a client that the
client had to bring to the
session before he or she arrived,
the willingness to make things better,
that would be the first thing.
Yeah.
Right.
So that,
and I've done therapy
that was court mandated.
Like,
I wouldn't recommend that.
That just doesn't work very well,
you know,
cause you can't force
someone to be better.
They have to kind of come already thinking
that there's a bunch of things they
don't know and that their life
could be better than it already is.
And that's a good position to take when
you're engaging in a conversation with
someone.
It's like,
look,
if you already know enough,
more power to you,
man,
you know,
but if you're suffering more
than you think is necessary,
which is like a highly probable or,
or more than you think is desirable,
which basically means if you're suffering
more than you think is desirable,
that means that you're way more
ignorant than you need to be.
Right.
That's what it means.
Because maybe you have an illness,
you don't know how to cure it.
Maybe you're having a fight with
someone you don't how to get out of it.
Maybe you're failing at work and
you don't know what to do about it.
It's like you're ignorant and no wonder
because people are ignorant and so you
might think,
well,
unless everything is just
the way you want it to be,
then you have something to
learn and then you think,
well maybe the person you're talking to,
no matter how
uncomfortable you are with their opinions
and how bent out of shape you think
they are,
maybe even how bent out of
shape they actually are.
There's always the possibility that
if you are actually engaged in a
conversation,
you ask them questions and you tried to
figure out what they thought that you'd
come away with one crumb of knowledge
more than you had when you went into the
conversation.
And like conversations like
that are a lot more interesting.
Guy Founded my,
no,
I've probably done 20,000
hours of clinical work,
something like that.
And so that's 20,000 hours of really,
really,
really serious conversations.
And they're almost always
interesting beyond belief.
And I'm like,
I've had clients that I told you already
that sort of span the entire spectrum
from people who were so
impaired cognitively and
behaviorally that while they
were utterly unemployable by any,
any reasonable standards to people who
were unbelievably high functioning,
and I found working with all of them,
if I,
if I'm in the zone properly,
it's ridiculously fascinating because
people are ridiculously interesting and so
and,
and everyone has their own characteristic
experience that's actually unique.
And so if you have a real conversation
with someone and they tell you what's
unique about their experience,
the probability that you can learn
something from that is it's lots,
it's certain that you can mind.
My Low Iq clients,
God,
they taught me so much.
It's just they taught me how
difficult things were first,
you know,
because to see someone struggle with
the task that the typical person can do
without even thinking sheds light on
exactly how amazing it is that that normal
people can do that and how hard it is
when when you were impaired to the point
where those sorts of normal
behaviors become become impossible.
It's so enlightening.
It teaches you a lot about the world.
And so I think part of the reason that
youtube is killing television is partly
because it's technologically advantageous.
I mean,
make no mistake about it.
There's nothing that TV can
do that youtube can't do.
And there's a whole bunch of
things that youtube can do.
The TV cat.
So it's obvious which one is going to win.
But what's also interesting about it
is that there seems to be a massive and
relatively untapped market
for actual conversation.
And it's because conversation is between
people of goodwill who are trying to
tell the truth.
We're trying to aim at making things
better is unbelievably valuable.
I mean,
at least in principle,
that's what we're all doing here,
right?
I mean,
even though you know,
you guys aren't talking,
um,
that doesn't mean this
isn't a conversation.
You know,
it's first of all,
we're trying to pay attention to you
at least enough to see if everyone is
engaged in the conversation.
If you're not engaged in it,
then it would be completely pointless.
Right?
And you want to take them
into your experiment.
That was amazing.
Well,
one of the things I learned in my clinical
practice is that if the conversation
was an interesting,
then I was doing it wrong.
Yeah,
it's great.
It's just that,
and that's a really cool thing too.
I think that also speaks to
this idea of a universal ethic.
I've really become
interested,
I talked about this with
Ian McGilchrist recently.
I just released that video today.
But what was up,
we could go on a different site.
I Bierly become interested in the
idea that the sense of engagement of
meaningful engagement is the
deepest of cognitive instincts.
I actually think you could make a very
strong neuro biological case for that and
that if you're engaged in something,
what it means is that you're
safe and secure on the one hand,
sufficiently safe and secure your
in your domain of competence,
which is a good place to be.
You know,
it's like explored territory.
So you're with within the
walls where you're safe,
but you're also peering over
the fence and at the same time,
right?
So if you're engaged,
what it means is that you're
in your domain of competence,
but you're operating within that domain
of competence so that you're expanding
your competence at the same time.
And so you feel that
as meaningfully engage,
meaningfully engaging.
And it is.
And so,
and I do also think that that sense
of meaningful engagement is the right
antidote to the suffering.
That's,
that's,
that's part and parcel
of our limited existence.
It's like you need an antidote to the
fact that life is suffering and the,
the experience of meaningful
engagement I think is that antidote.
And I also think that the experience of
meaningful engagement is a marker that
you're,
where you should be doing what
you should be at the right time.
I think it's the deepest
of cognitive instincts.
And so that's really cool man.
If that was true,
I think it's actually true.
So if you bring something,
if that was true,
man,
so,
but I think it is.
So when we're trying to see if
it works and that state of flow,
you lose a sense of time.
Yeah.
When you lose your self
consciousness too as well.
So that's something that's worth thinking.
But I would also consider that
a primary religious experience.
It's something like that.
Yeah.
You know,
you're talking about science and religion
earlier and like there's a bunch of
questions that we need to address
pretty seriously about that too.
Because the scientific
kind of atheist types,
you know,
they're very down on the idea of religion.
But that's a very bad idea because
religion is a human universal,
right.
And religious experience.
People have religious experiences.
It's like at the minimum we
need an explanation for that.
Plus you can induce them,
which is also,
you know,
you can't,
you can't just write that off.
Like you can induce religious experiences.
I can be intertwined with
that spiritual as well.
Right?
Yeah.
Religious,
spiritual.
So,
but it's,
it's not,
it's not just conceptual.
Like,
you know,
you can say,
well,
there's this spiritual realm.
It's deeply experiential.
You have to be Jordan,
are we in a computer simulation?
Ah,
um,
if we are,
it's within a computer
that we don't understand.
Um,
I look at questions like
that or are strange because,
um,
welcome to simulation.
Well,
it's like it's,
it's like asking whether you can reduce
consciousness to material to material
substrate.
And the answer to that is,
but by the time we reduced
consciousness to its material substrate,
our understanding of what
that material substrate is,
we'll have transformed so dramatically
that it won't look very much like the
material substrate that we presume now.
And so if we're in a simulation,
then it's within the confines
of a mechanism that we
can't easily assimilate to
our own computational devices.
And then of course the other
question like that as well,
we've already defined this as reality.
And so his reality,
a simulation,
it's,
well,
no,
by definition it's not.
It's you might say,
well,
the simulation can get so real that
you can't distinguish it from reality.
You start to
almost all questions of the form is a
B devolve down to it depends on how you
define a and B.
Because the problem with questions like
that is it decontextualizes the terms,
right?
It's like,
well,
what do you mean by reality?
What do you mean by simulation?
Well,
if you mean the same
thing by both of them,
then they're the same thing.
If you mean different
things by both of them,
then there are different things.
And so
I'm serious about that.
[inaudible]
well most of the time you
can't pull single terms out
of a conversational stream
and assumed that the term has a bounded
definition that's self evident using
only that term.
Because when we converse it's like,
well you utter a stream of words.
It's like,
well what are the words mean?
It depends on where
they are in the phrase.
It depends on where they
are in the sentence.
It depends on where the sentence
is located in the paragraph.
It depends on the context within
which the paragraph is uttered.
And you triangulate all
of that simultaneously.
Extract out the meaning of the word.
And then if you take a word out,
like it's a thing and another word out,
like it's a thing.
And you say,
are these two things the same?
You're acting as if those words can be
decontextualized and they have absolute
meaning in their decontextualize
state and they don't.
So,
so,
so usually those questions I would say
in some sense or philosophically are
philosophically untenable.
So,
so,
well that's the answer to that.
[inaudible]
for those of you that haven't done
self authoring or understand myself,
they are incredible programs.
There's a 20% off code San Fran.
Okay.
So give that a go.
Thanks Jordan,
appreciate you.
I appreciate you coming out
here and San Francisco Bay area.
Really enjoyed having you.
We hope to have you again soon.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
thank you very much.
Fun.
[inaudible].